another mistake that that writers make
is they they have a single goal that
they have ascribed to their protagonist
their main character and because if the
character just went on a straight line
they'd achieve the goal in 15 20 30
pages they create obstacles to keep the
character from the gold conflict but in
a comedy you often have your initial
goal which is based upon the wrong
thinking of the character and then you
have the eventual true goal which the
character only discovers midway through
the film I can think of dozens of films
like that where we're in Groundhog Day
Bill Murray just wants to be a
newscaster a weatherman at a bigger
station and then along the way he
realizes that he loves Rita and he wants
to get Rita uh in uh in in wedding
crashers their goal is just to bang as
many women as they want but then he
meets the girl and then it all becomes
how do i how do I get with her if I if
I'd been a fraud my my whole life so
more important than then creating
obstacles to impede your hero from
attaining the goal you want to create
learning moments aha moments primal
moments moments of discovery moments of
Revelation that teach your hero give
your hero something like you know in
Chris Vogler's the hero's journey you're
actually giving him the magic implements
that he'll be able to use later on to
you know solve the problem to save the
princess
Shrek talking about saving a princess
again
Shrek just starts off wanting people out
of the swamp get everybody out of my
swamp and then in order to do that they
give them another task I have to go save
the princess but in order to do that
after I have to beat the dragon but in
order that i beaten the dragon or
actually the dragons fall in love with
my donkey uh now I have to get
the princess back just to get my swamp
back to normal
but by then he's fall in love with the
princess and he wants the princess so
his goals change your initial goal is
often not the goal your your protagonist
ends up with or ends up trying to
achieve so those sounds like there's
many goals along the way me well well
things that come out of the first goal
but then there's all there's usually our
revelation realization that the
character has that the that they need
they want a different goal they want
something else
you